[Music]
l
h
[Music]
for
[Applause]
St
for
e
[Music]
over
BR get
[Music]
out
can't
[Music]
than
e
[Music]
spe
you
[Music]
for
this
[Music]
the
for
[Music]
you
for
[Music]
[Applause]
o
excellencies ladies and gentlemen I'd
like to welcome you to this European
memorial for the former president of the
European commission Jack delore our
ceremony will begin with a an address
from the presid of the European
commission Mrs OA
ferion Madam president you have the
[Music]
floor members of's family excellencies
ladies and
gentlemen
courage Europe spring is still ahead of
us these words come from the last speech
which
ja made before the European Parliament
on the 19th of January
1995 a few days before the end of his 10
years tenure as president of
theion these
words demonstrate op M about the
European
project even more so his
optimism the strong determination of a
man who was always always sought to
combine ideals and action a lot has been
said over recent weeks about Jack delore
the architect of
Europe on the profound link which the
links which created for future
generations and which meant that he
became one of the three honor citizens
of Europe along with je and helmet
Co not as enough I think has been said
about his belief his faith in Europe as
a community of Destiny we know
thator was a Believer a man of faith
and he was also a man who
was
convinced human beings become themselves
by being part of society and working for
the wellbeing
of human
beings he lived firsthand the hard
history of Europe and of its tragic
human
consequences and all this into
his
that our Horizon should be that of an
ever closer Union between the European
nations and the people of
Europe in
a Europe of Peace Li and solidarity a
moral
historic Horizon and at the same time a
practical solution to the challenges we
faced as he said himself in addressing
the European Parliament let me
quote Europe which is threatened by its
own divisions remains deeply ened by its
diversity we must preserve these and
even more so we
must develop them further for the common
good
this community of
Destiny had to be based
on principle of Subs subsidiarity
respecting pluralism and therefore
diversity as he put it the European
Union which he sought to build did not
set out to replace the nation states and
we find this philosophy in the current
motto of the European Union which is
United in
diversity this European
ideal as jacor liked call it it was not
a mere intellectual exercise or simply a
statement of
faith it was in fact the driving force
of hugely important initiatives and we
still feel the effects of these today
let us not
forget at the beginning
of the
1980s this was a period
which was often commentators often
referred to as eurosclerosis years of
economic crisis and
political and a European Community which
seemed absent
paralyzed as soon as he was appointed
president of the commission ja
understood that we had to get
this Lo lotive
work regain the trust of
Europeans and to do so by a series of
initiatives which would represent
fundamental change and open up a whole
new Dynamic but of course it was very
important that governments be able to
fully support these changes after wide
ranging consultations Jac delore decided
to work with what we already had the
heart the European community and that
was the
1992 the goal for
1992 objective 1992 a very ambitious
project to create a single Market
of Europeans a space Without
Borders and a space with freedom of
movement for goods of
course but also for capital for service
and equally important for
people this therefore was to be a lever
which could re launch the European
economy and make it more competitive it
also involved appealing to European
citizens calling on them to make the
European space their owning
this achieved a great result
relaunching Europe based
on
economy creating optimism right in the
middle
of an economic crisis and nonetheless I
think the real Revolution was elsewhere
it was institutional in
nature the European single
act my favor treaty as he liked to call
it not just the single European Act
which reaffirmed the objective for
1992 but
also he made
sure it had the
necessary
institutional means to achieve it
typical of
which competition which stimulates
cooperation which strengthens and
solidarity which unites and he did that
in a number of
ways by widening
the scope of qualified majority
decision- making which is a
key extending European competences in
the fields of industrial policy research
and the
environment and finally and most
importantly in putting
social Regional cohesion at the heart of
the Europe's priorities
allow me just to spend a few moments on
this latter
aspect
dimension of
Europe for
JA was an essential condition for
economic
growth territorial
cohesion to reduce the divergences
between the member states and between
the
regions social cohesion
combat
inequality Dimension was very important
to Jac delore is strong component of
social dialogue he promoted this in
particular with
the
discussions progress in competitiveness
and
solidarity this philosophy uh has been
handed down to us as our inheritance and
continues to guide our action many
reforms have followed in the wake of the
single European act starting with the m
treaty which put all these new policies
on an even firmer basis
m
m treat which put in place a a European
union and which allowed
the treaty which launched the economic
and monetary Union and the introduction
of the Euro the Euro which was a
major step
forward promoted by Ja this was a symbol
of a closer Union and also a tool to
achieve greater
economic efficiency and sovereignty
excellences ladies and
gentlemen it would be wrong of me to
celebrate not to celebrate this builder
of an integrated competitive and solid
AR based Europe at the same time ja Tor
was very concerned about Europe's place
and role in the world and as he put it
we have a choice between renew or
decline he was quite convinced that
Europe had to reaffirm its role in the
world and play a full a full role the
world he beli that this could only be
done through shared sovereignty and the
instruments needed for that such as The
single currency which he helped to put
in place and a common
defense he very much hoped to see this
and hoped and called for it to happen
but it never did and as he put it
let us be strong enough to ensure that
we are respected and can promote our
values freedom and solidarity in World
such as ours there is no alternative end
of
quotation Liberty
solidarity
are fundamental humanistic
values which need to be promoted in an
unstable and uncertain world with the
end of the Iron
Curtain this belief became a reality was
caught up in
history as a German who lived in a
divided country I am very grateful to
Jac delor for his
commit in favor of reuniting
German and his belief that Europe would
one day be
reunited
indeed as of a
1989 was very
clear confidence that
the of European
integration win the day answering German
journalists who um questioned him on the
12th of November 1989 just a few days
after the fall of the
wall
the European Community is the center of
gravity of Europe's history and it is
toward the European community that the
citizens of ger Democratic rep Republic
hung are looking and we must not
disappoint we must offer them our
support and
our cooperation end of
quotation and thanks to and on his
initiative Europe put in place the far
these were the first
instruments designed to support the
countries of Central Eastern Europe in
their efforts to modernize and to move
closer to the European Union we all know
the famous copen cagen
criteria aded at the Copenhagen Summit
in June
1993 guided the most
ambitious enlargement process that
Europe had ever undergone and it Remains
the foundation of
what when it comes to Europe's role in
the world he hadn't even wider vision
and it was the commission under
President Jac delore which played began
to play a key role in major
International fora such as the G7 and
the G20 the Rio
conference predecessor of the
cop and I couldn't help smiling when I
read an article in a newspaper which
described a meeting between Jack delore
and Bill Clinton at the White House in
1994 what were they talking about was
the question
the about the threat of American tariffs
on steel imports from Europe comat some
battles continue
forever
[Music]
ja appreciate and agree was a master
technician a patient
negotiator and no doubt he honed these
skills during his years as a trade
unionist they proved very useful in the
European cont context because in order
to
persuade Germans to accept the Euro this
these were essential
qualities as he said not all Germans
believe in God but they all believe in
the bundes
bank with his typical sense of humor and
I can confirm
he so this shows how much he achieved
patience rigor hard
work
spending as long as it takes to work on
each proposal so that each proposal is
perfect and each argument carries the
day and we know that Jac delore was a
very hard worker but also with on the
horizon always a an effort to make
progress for Europe and for its citizens
excellencies ladies and gentlem
I believe rather than just remembering
this inheritance from we must keep the
flame
alive the flame of Youth and the arasmus
programs solidarity in the structural
funds and the
social goal of the ambitious pragmatic
goals that we set out to achieve because
we have to reinvent the path that Europe
follows every day
used to describe the European Union as
an OP a non unidentified political
object Tau
us the key is to adop to new realities
and new needs have to with ambition and
realism to tackle new
challenges key is to always keep in our
Hearts the European ideal farewell Jack
delore Long Live
[Applause]
[Music]
Europe the great ambition of our
European effort is to continue and to
maintain a soul at the same
[Music]
time
real
[Music]
re
minimum
[Music]
m
real
[Music]
for
don't
[Music]
w
thank you moving on I like to give the
floor to the Belgian prime minister Mr
Alexander prime minister you have the
floor M
Madame members of mr's family Madame
President dear
colleagues today we're paying tribute to
The Life and Legacy of a great
man as Belgium takes over the rting
presidency of the Council of the
European Union it is time to focus on
shor's remarkable
achievements he too took up the Reigns
of the European Commission a key moment
when the project of United Europe was
battered by unprecedented
challenges the leadership which he
showed over decisive years made it
possible to lay foundations for
integration which we benefit from
today in the early
19990s Europe was dealing with the
consequences of the Cold War and
economic crisis ja showed
determination consious as he was of the
difficulties that his family and he
experienced during the war Hew he drew
lessons from that difficult period these
were lessons which fed into his
commitment to conflict prevention and
unity the war in Ukraine and the ongoing
troubles in the Middle East require once
again a collective response on the part
of our
democracies ja had understood that Unity
was our greatest strength particularly
in times of
adversity it is in unity that we find
strength diversity is our greatest asset
and it is cooperation which allows us to
tackle the challenges however difficult
they may be said this great
European and these words continue to
resonate with
me insiration from his legacy so that
ctively we can come to the aid of the
Ukrainian people who are coming
timelessly an unfair and brutal Invasion
which Ukraine did not
provoke tomorrow when we meet to discuss
the financial aid which will be needed
for Ukraine we need to show the same
level of UN
our
support is not limited to Mere words our
support a contribution to the
independence and freedom of the
Ukrainian
people Ukraine gives a brutal reminder
of how important our Collective Strength
is Ja had appreciated that United Europe
was not only a political ideal but also
embodied a hope for all Europeans who
Inspire for peace and
stability to conclude I like to
underline how much's achievements have
benefited our fellow
citizens
REM free movement of services Capital
people between member states and the
impact on small and medium Enterprises
has been
thanks to the single Market companies
have access to a market of over 440
million consumers small mediumsized
Enterprises have hugely benefited from
this and employ over 100 million people
moreover of the Euro another Legacy of
jacor has once again facilitated
economic
integration the Euro has become a symbol
of
unity
feeling of European identity amongst our
citizens we are
aware more integration is needed the
European project is still to be
completed be assured you can rely on the
Belgian presidency in promoting
cooperation between member
states seeking compromises between memb
states of the European Union is a
delicate but necessary
task I would hope that Jack delore will
rest in peace his contribs will continue
for a long time to come to forge the
destiny of our Union and I'd like to
thank you for your
[Applause]
attention thank you Mr thank you Mr
Prime Minister Let Me Now call to the
podium the prime minister Portugal Mr
Antonio kto you have the floor Mr Prime
[Music]
Minister M dear
colleagues dear ladies and gentlemen
ladies and
gentlemen ja
is Founding Father of the European
Union and we
owe deep and wider Europe today the
single European
Act and the
master are practical examples of what
jaor achieved in leading us on the road
to ever closer Union with ja Europe has
also become wider not just deeper put
together the
South
Integra new democracies in Portugal and
today a tribute to him by declaring a
national day of morning followed then by
Austria Sweden and
fin
ja made a key contribution to German
unification and to the historic
decisions in 1993 in Copenhagen which
on of the IR C opened up the road to the
wide enlargement toward Central and
Europe shor's
contribution building new
Europe only be
understood taking into account the
values he held as a politician who
belied and said that the social
Dimension is the go my
reflection of my
action
he as a
militant social movements as
a as a milit of the French Socialist
Party Minister fr's government and then
as president of the European commission
for economic and social C where the key
and Final of the construction of Europe
which was built on a social market
economy which described in terms of
Trilogy competition which stimulates
cooperation which strengthens and
solidarity which unites and by making
this a reality he help to give birth to
the single market and to the cohesion
policy which are mutually reinforcing
cohesion along with conver
strengthen the single market and the
deeping of the single Market in turn
streng the
solidarity this is why social dialogue
in view
of was so essential to growing and
shared launched the European
social which have continued ever since
this explains
to why he beli monetary
Union not be a success
without
economic the different responses by the
European Union to the EUR crisis the
crisis caused by
pmic show how
right in
2020 along with working with
European Union was able to react
effectively to the
econom this time the M States trust each
other and had trust in the European
commission we were able to put in place
sure and generation EU and as a result
of this millions of jobs
were
and Swift economic Ladi recovery and
gentlemen became possible Jack delore
Legacy
is as relevant today as it was when he
finished his second mandate had had of
the European commission today's ceremony
is therefore more than just a tribute to
is memory it is an opportunity to look
for inspiration in that Legacy first to
complete what he began the single Market
the economic monetary Union and social
Europe a strong European social pillar
is essential to boost Trust of European
citizens in our capacity to deal with
with
globalization and the digital and
climate transitions while leaving no one
behind
secondly like the fall of the Berlin
Wall in
1989 the Russian invasion of Ukraine
makes further enlargement an imperative
once again the European Union must play
a decisive role as a geopolitical global
actor as Jack delore understood for
enlargement to be a success the European
Union must prepare and that means
reforming a reformed human Union needs
to be simultaneously
enlarge and deepen more flexible and
more cohesive it needs to be a common
home with our common values as a solid
and deep
foundations and where all member states
can feel comfortable to be clear we need
a Europe that continues to make no
concessions on Democracy fundamental
rights or and the rule of law
and at the same time that preserves our
Unity by accepting and respecting that
different member states desire different
levels of
integration finally we should not forget
that at the heart of the Lord's
successful reforms was the capacity to
March growing Ambitions with necessary
resources considering today's world we
don't have the luxury to reduce our
common Ambitions therefore we need to
increase our common investment capacity
in the digital and climate transitions
in security and defense in migration in
enlargement and never forgetting Jac
delore in Social cohesion that means
making difficult choices it means
finding the right balance but new own
resources will have to be part of the
solution in the nutshell Europe
cannot
overpromise and underd
deliver ladies and gentlemen Madame and
M to conclude the memory of jacqu delore
and the success of his legacy shouldn't
make us think that those years were a
walk in the park as Jack Dore himself
used to say the construction of Europe
will never be a quiet River what we need
to learn from him is the ability to
transform crisis and challenges into
opportunities to build a stronger more
resilient and more cisive Europe seeking
inspiration in the legacy of jacqu
delore is the best way to pay tribute to
his memory
[Applause]
obri
let thank you Mr Prime Minister let us
now move on to our first musical intute
God Bless the Child by Billy
Holiday
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
all
[Applause]
thank you we will now hear some
statements from close friends and
collaborators of jaor the first
from
count former vice president of the
European commission who is now president
of the Europe seor law reflection group
uh count you have the
[Music]
floor
I feel real
emotion and speaking about the man who
honored me with his friendship but I'm
going to try to do so
nonetheless our collaboration and our
friendship was
born at the time when was chairman of
the economic Affairs Committee of the
European
and when I had submitted a resting plan
for the steel
industry and that proposal was far from
meeting with
consensus in
fact Fierce opposition to this proposal
from Minister L who also became a friend
of
mine
and when he was fly opposed to something
that was really quite something but you
see that we can survive
nonetheless when I as a commissioner
wondered whether I
had a
chance occupying the wonderful position
of president of the commission I asked
him whether he would be interested in
this because if he were
interested
then I would
haveed other paths you can't be a rival
of
Jack well at that stage he told me that
he wish to
remain as Min of economic Affairs and
Finance in France
pres that would change however when
President appointed
Fab is the next prime minister and
not and that's what to
Brussels that of course was good for
Brussels and for
Europe rather strange for us as belgians
he actually liked
Brussels something of a surprise
actually
Mar his wife and
he and they
joined the progam offered by wives uh uh
and representatives and so on and we
also discovered that we like football
matches
together he became a supporter of
and and real
supporter he whistled at the
referee he question
decision and he was even more
enthusiastic in that than I was but we
had at
theate so he could enjoy
the and
uh the
gastronomy
now throughout my long career if there
is one thing of which I'm proud
Mar dear
Martin that is that he honored me with
his friendship thank
[Applause]
you
thank you let me now invite Madame
former member of the Jack delore cabinet
and vice president of the Europe Jack
delore group Madam P you have the
[Music]
floor
thank you very much
indeed Madam
president exes ladies and
gentlemen it is of course a great honor
to before you
today even greater honor speaking after
Mr
and and others but I also feel very
strong sense of
emotion as Martin
knows very close to ja and she very
kindly said that it was reciprocated his
part I would like to talk to you about
briefly about three
aspects firstly one which is not that
well
known not very many people say
this
promoted a new development model as he
called it and this new model
development inspired in particular by
his visit to Rio 1992 when I had the
honor and good luck to accompany him
ja was Tred as an economist very sound
background years in the he had a very
strong social
conscience
as
[Music]
member economic and
socials in his vision of the world
Chernobyl was a first warning sign and
real he took a third dimension on board
in His World Vision environment when we
came back from Rio he asked number of
cabinet members to help
him devel vision for sustainable
development in all three chapters for
Europe and that became chapter 10 of the
white paper on growth employment and
sustainability which opened up
new ways forward into the 21st century
and you will find some
very elements that the circular economy
for
example a tax reform which shows very
clearly how in his view one could
combine the the environmental economic
and the social Dimensions he wanted
natural resources to be more heavily
taxed to discourage waste and
overuse and he wanted to reduce um tax
unemployment to
encourage many of these ideas were not
implemented straight away some were
never
implemented have fed into eventually the
green favored the tax on co2 and you
wanted this tax to be adopted just
before real and that was became a
reality it was adopted in principle but
it never became a reality and turned
into something which didn't work very
well which is
ETS but ETS with a green deal and fit
for looking to the Future can
become real and have a real effect these
three dimensions of sustainable
development can be very useful in the
situation in which we find
ourselves of course
deal essential the level of ambition was
essential we are facing a real crisis
our planet is fa facing a crisis and we
must rise to this
challenge but of course this cannot
neglect economic and social realities
it
is this awareness
that if it were needed this is what the
Revolt by Farmers is is showing uh the
need to better take on board the social
Dimension when implementing the green
deal I would just like to mention uh a
couple of personal memories and
Impressions one is his amazing
pedagogical skills on one occasion I was
in the car with him on the way to
Luxembourg for the 40th um anniversary
of the co and Steel Community treaty he
started
with we started by reading L keep
newspaper in the morning all about
football um or cycling and other
sporting
events after that he turned his notes
and then he turned to me and said jenv
do you think people really understand
you
jenv I'm afraid not if you want people
to understand you write for a 5-year-old
child so that's what I try to do after
that and that is what I have tried to
put across to the people who work with
me second
memory uh he didn't like
acronyms and he really
complained uh every time we came to the
meetings he was chairing cabinet
meetings uh which was about once a week
uh very often around uh around breakfast
he would always complain about new
acronyms and always say that citizens
simply won't understand if you do that I
had an an example of this yesterday
myself I went to France as part of the
starfish or ocean Mission meeting on
that subject and I wasn't quite clear
whether this
Mission whether it it's had really
become become a a reality or not why so
uh because one had lost track in some
rather strange terms somewhat potic
poetic at times but which masked
the essence of the commission's uh
actions and and
Mission let
[Music]
me remind myself of what it what it was
called Blue Mission Med
uh behind that you have
projects which really arouse great
enthusiasm and it hides as well the
European Dimension I would say so I was
reassured by how this mission is playing
out but I've also
become even more convinced that ja was
right about not overdoing acronyms in
the European commission thank
you
mer thank you very much the next
statement will be from enrio
lettera speaking as president of the Jac
delore Institute Mr letter you have the
floor
sir this afternoon at
4:00
I had um a happy event that I got used
to in meeting Jac delore it's always
interesting to hear what he had to say
Martin those was so much at OD with what
we experience nowadays there was no need
for his part to impose his uh point of
view or his discourse on the contrary he
showed respect and interest for his
interlocutor without
uh at the same time failing to be simple
and limpid I think being simp simp
rather than complex is more difficult
but more useful he was curious about the
present and uh concern to have a better
future but he was also able to talk
about the past he was always uh taking
up uh uh curiosity points he wasn't was
somebody who was
nostalgic he talked about
uh night time negotiations uh for the
arasmus project I asked him when
everything started
the night negotiations we had
discussions on Mrs Thatcher on shortterm
tax uh concessions uh uh in exchange for
the longterm gain of the arasmus project
he was concerned about young
people they regularly asked for news
about how the young students programs
was uh progressing and the our Europe
Institute that we set up and in eight
years it trained hundreds of young
people he'll be laughing up up there in
knowing that on his behalf we launch the
first edition of the Jack delore
European Agora that will take place in
the first week of July 2024 this will
bring bring together hundreds of young
people from across Europe and that will
be in uh antona Altona uh a town that he
loved Lisbon the uh Europe was one of
cities and uh regions he wanted to bring
together citizens citizens were part of
his plan for Europe the Jack La involved
commitment to Citizens that interin our
founding values he showed great interest
in the recent
developments uh of citizens involvement
in the conference on the future of
Europe he was very uh fond of people and
the depths of the human soul he had very
fine judgment he was able to delegate
and above all he could judge
people he could get people to talk as
only a person could do who could look
into the soul of a human being he was a
great Confessor in other words he showed
a great interest in how his creature the
European Union progressed if a society
without memory had no future at the same
time he was neither uh nostalgic or
Heering back to the past he saw changes
in the world and sort a Europe which
would change and would be commentate for
meeting the challenges a world that
double its population in 30 years that's
exactly when he talked about me at the
last meeting at 400 p.m. on the rout San
jaac when I asked advice on the rep
report on the future of the single
Market he said that you have to
completely change your
orientation you have to uh reset the
compass 40 years ago we had to start
from the inside and above all govern
relations between France and Germany now
we now to look outwards how the European
Union in unity uh takes up its position
uh Visa the rest of the world and then
we need to remember that when we
launched the single
Market we not I but when we another
Nuance which had a great deal about his
internal strength he didn't like playing
games this was a success yes because at
the same time we launched the cohesion
policy you were cor right Mrs felion in
underscoring that key aspect without
cohesion there is no competitiveness in
the single Market hence his intention
and I'm going to conclude on the note to
have a great Europe these 10 years were
those of the Europe of
12 but he looked much further than that
on how many occasions did he talk to me
about the activities of The Institute we
had to move beyond the existing 12
member states in particular dear Donald
he referred to Poland and the hope that
one day there would be a jacqu delore
Institute in
waro uh hence the recent setting up of
The Institute of the center for the
great
Europe the uh world's response to his
death has struck us shows that Europe
does have a soul it shows that Europe is
also and above all rest something that
rests on sentiments emotions and
passions in other words its fight has to
continue to be based on the idea of we
and not I with citizens for the future
of young people thank
you Mercy
let us now move on uh to a musical
interlude before hearing other
statements to a Wild Rose by sunny
rolands
[Music]
h
[Applause]
let me now give the floor to Madame
pervan Perez former member of the
European Parliament Madame perz you have
the
[Music]
floor sh Jack dear Jack I remember your
advice when I was elected as chair of
the economic and monetary Affairs
Committee of the European Parliament in
2004 this was a post that I was taking
over with great uh Pride from you you
told me how much this post would allow
me to influence promote the ideas that
were dear to us and that uh I should
respond with a smile to the nastiness to
which one can be subject in public life
I've tried to implement that advice and
I cherish
it I recall your
foresight from the single act onwards
you needed no one to realize that Europe
would have to address environmental
questions I recall one of your last
public statements in March 2020 at the
start of the covid crisis the lack of
solidarity means that the European Union
is in Mortal danger the microb is back I
remember your round face uh alongside
the firm firmness of your thought how
blue your eyes were and your mischievous
uh look I remember your admiration and
your tenderness when you talked about
Martin thank you for introduced me to
the pukit restaurant and the vello
tanato there you engaged in dinner
diplomacy to create the conditions for
dialogue where you were used to inviting
your UTS over lunch to bring up whatever
issues still had to be resolved as a
member of the European Parliament you
refus to engage in institutional guilla
tactics uh thank you that as a president
of the commission you sought cooperation
and then co-decision for the European
Parliament thank you for giving us a bad
habitate of being those for whom you
kept the best of your proposals thank
you for having believed in the sense of
our words for those who defined your
mandate for those who used you who gave
you the sense to convince to bring
forward accession and to transform thank
you for defending the ideas of the man
that you
were you Incorporated your ideas and
your ambition for them the unity of a
man I'm not sure he came up with this
title but uh hats off because that
really did Define your quiet in a
strength thank you for what he gave us
as a
legacy including the Shor institutes and
they bear a a great burden for this you
were concerned to be
useful uh but you were man out of your
time in public in private you were a
Social Democrat and a Christian you were
French but not a Jacobin you were not a
federalist you're in favor of a
Federation of nation states you worked
with Shak shabon Delmas
andam and you exploited your
experience following on from your own
vision of the world you were a committed
trade unionist highly political and had
great integrity for you it was important
to deal with economic and social matters
first and foremost but you liked
politics rather than politicking even if
you know all the ins and outs of that
you were a magician in using all the
potential of the powers that you had you
were a man of dialogue and your
preferred weapon was education but if
you had to wanted to bring someone
around you had to be prepared to have a
discussion behind closed doors to speak
bluntly and you didn't hesitate to use
that you were both serious and full of
humor you were important and simple you
loved Europe and we love
[Applause]
you thank you very much then next
statement will be by Mr Eno landaburu
former director General in the European
[Music]
commission since the 27th of December
many tributes have been
held and paid in memory of sha
delore the most uh solemn Majestic one
was perhaps in laned in Paris at the
beginning of
January and we saw many tributes to
Anonymous tributes in the social media
on TV and radio to express the feelings
and gratitude of ordinary people for
this uh man I think this event Madame
President is all the more important
because
here in the very heart of Brussels which
he loved so much in this
institution which he cherished and loved
uh because for him the commission was
and had to be a laboratory for to ideas
about the future of Europe but also the
motor that
uh moved the European project forward
here I had a few
experiences with him during his two
terms of office over 10 years I would
just mention
firstly his willingness
exceptional ability to
listen and he could even do that with
his own administration because from time
to time he would come and join our
meeting of uh directors General in the
commission
to Inspire us with his uh
will political will to share his ideas
about the current situation situation
with us and to listen to what we had to
say about various initiatives which he
was uh proposing and in the same way
he not just informed us but motivated us
so that when we returned to our
respective director General that we
would motivate all our
staff there was uh a sense of symbiosis
between the administration which
sometimes was neglected even despised by
politicians and this ability to
implement this extraordinary political
project which he
uh created and he also loved to
go into thei fi as it were in the
territories to meet uh
citizens and he often brought me with
him uh on these visits because he was
really interested and able to listen to
people I remember in particular one trip
we made to an an area which he knew well
and loved that of his wife who comes
from The
Basque and of course he was in a good
mood he wasn't always um he could
sometimes times uh be U Less um in less
Good Humor but he he clearly enjoyed
meeting people in The Basque country and
I
remember that there was a one hour
session meeting with local
farmers in the area and the meeting
didn't really get off to such a great
start there was tension in the air there
were key real issues uh to discuss with
the farmers and the the meeting though
ended up lasting 2 and a half hours the
whole program was completely upset or
the organizers were not very happy but
he insisted on staying and at the end of
this 2 and 1 half hour meeting which was
mental as one hour well what
happened you saw a a smile and a jovial
atmosphere uh and a a sense of trust
which had being created by
listening uh and speaking he was able to
inspire these people with with trust and
now at a time when we see a new Revolt
by Farmers uh this I think was a very
useful lesson as uh Madame President and
prime minister kosa said we should not
forget the key element of social uh and
Regional
cohesion these were absolutely key
elements in his whole approach which
helped make the single
Market uh a a working reality I remember
um our many uh many meetings and trips
uh where he was able to convince the
member states to increase the budget to
make a success of Social and Regional
cohesion coh to correct some of the gaps
and the
shortcomings uh faced by lagging region
so social and Regional cohesion wasn't
just a question of redistribution and
solidarity which are very dear to his
heart but also a question of being in
touch with the needs of uh the neediest
people in our Union uh I remember also a
meeting with filipo Gonzales who was
then our prime minister in
Spain um dialogue with a number of
citizens one of them timidly raised his
hand and said Mr President I would just
like to speak in my own name and on
behalf of the C my fellow citizen in
Andalusia uh just to say how much we
appreciate all the support that Europe
has brought us it enables us not just to
have a better life but to feel that we
belong to a family and I'll never forget
that uh
statement because as uh enrio Lea said
earlier perhaps Europe has a soul it's
not just a question of redistributing
money but it's also a question a feeling
uh that we belong to a family in a way
that goes beyond just
numbers uh just a little anecdote in the
Spanish Socialist Party there were a
number of us who focused on European
Affairs um and and uh good friends Pepe
Bell was one of
them and I recall that we used when we
were talking about
jacore to refer to him as FR
Jaca have you seen did you see what F
fro jaac has been up to uh why fro
jaac I think you can guess that for
yourselves thank you very much
now we invite Pascal former head of
cabinet of
Shor uh
all uh
at a time when on Europe's doorsteps the
bomb blasts the horror of Destruction
lost lives haunt us once again I would
like just
briefly to touch upon a less known
aspect of jacqu
delore uh and it's less known
understandably so because he always
wanted to be discreet about it and here
I'm referring to his
actions in order
to uh resolve certain armed
conflicts and to forge peace his
father as Martin will remember was
seriously wounded in the first world war
and he
inculcated in him the hope of never
again as people said at the
time when that hope was
disappointed uh marked forever the young
man caught in the debark of
1939 he hated
violence it's that
delore that I
saw acting as a
peacemaker on two occasions during his
time as head of the commission one
failed the other
succeeded the first was when with Shimon
Perez he tried to build a regional water
Community between Israel Palestine and
their
neighbors this was a simple
idea very often as so often taking its
inspiration from the colon Steel
Community in the
1950s this was drawn up and uh reworked
in
secret with the involvement of several
bright Minds including AI Prima who at
the time was Ambassador of Israel to
Brussels this community as we know
unfortunately never came to light
unfortunately the
second here this was successful was in
Northern Ireland following on from his
visit to 1992 in
1992 and uh here thanks to a network of
uh contacts which had been uh built in
the wings to speak this allowed him at
the request of the parties to the
conflict to devise a cooperation program
funded by the European budget to
accompany the 1994
ceasefire this program was
adopted by the European Council in Essen
at the end of what you might call the
delore ERA this was a high point if you
like the Reverb verber of which can
still be felt because this program is
the only one that has survived
brexit in those moments as in so many
others delore embodied a
mixture a very particular
mixture within him and that was constant
of ambition and
modesty and I'm going to illustrate this
by way of an anecdote uh which I'll
offer to you to bring this uh testimony
to uh close on a lighter
note this brings us to early
theore newly
installed as president of the
commission paid a visit to fra meeting
at the El
Palace a portico 30 uh crossed through
many times as an advisor or as a
minister a
minister as well a courtyard that he
passed across as an advisor or a
minister Ministry Ministry of Home
Affairs on many occasions he saw the
soldiers of the Republican guard on the
steps in dress
uniform
saluting
uh heads of state and government as set
out by the protocol in France and once
he heard the first drum rules he said oh
my
goodness that's what he said to me they
seem to be waiting for somebody
important come along then let's go in uh
by the back
door
thank
you to all of you in this
room
excellencies
ministers officials former members of uh
the delore private office and everybody
following us on the screens in the bmore
thank you for all of us for helping in
this evening to accompany Jac delore as
he goes out through the front door thank
you in particular uh for for
that for having taken the initiative of
arranging this Memorial
ceremony Madame President of the
European
commission uh thank you for him and
thank you for
us
mer thank
[Music]
you
for
[Music]
la
thank you once again to our Orchestra
this now brings our uh this event to a
conclusion I now invite you to join us
for a reception in the area in front of
this room just behind you thank
[Music]
you